um
[Laughter]
hey everybody happy friday
hopefully
i'm looking at a little connection here
i know we say this every time well
because might be fine my little phone uh
i used up all my data for the month
which that's not too bad because there's
only like a little bit more than a week
left
um so i don't have a backup right but so
far
little green square remains green
yeah so
hopefully it'll be coming all right
i know but you know how i worry about it
pookie ran in she threw the door wide
open like hey i'm in here i'm here
i can't understand it pookie you you
relax
yeah well she's been sleeping all day
stop prop says sound you guys can hear
me right
yeah i mean you know this that shit's
still on you didn't touch it so you
didn't turn it off
it looks like it's on maybe maybe your
sound is down maybe yeah
sandra's back i know that's what i was
just gonna tell you like when you came
back in here her name is who still has
her jawline she has
[Laughter]
sandra you're so full of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you come on this show you talk all this
[ __ ] but you never show any [ __ ]
photos to yourself you're [ __ ]
talking and then and then well she likes
to retain an air of mystery that's a
woman's prerogative she said she was
skinny fat
german
i want to see that belly
[Laughter]
tom looks at everyone like a side of
beef i look at everybody like a side of
bee look at myself like a side of beef i
just got back from a biker bar
i've been drinking all day he went to
the biker bar yeah the bike was drinking
all day i was actually gonna have to
push the time of the show back because
it was like getting to be 4 30 and i'm
like uh is he coming back today yeah of
course to come back of course i can't
well i don't know you could be dead in
the ditch somebody no they bought me
four [ __ ] drinks
and you rode back on a motorcycle on
that yeah don't tell people that oh no i
drank like [ __ ] eight don't tell me
that i had like eight
see this is why i thought you were dead
in a ditch somewhere because i figured
that that's probably what it happened i
was drinking black velvet
if you please yeah if you guys know what
black velvet is that's sucking um
guinness stout
and a hard cider
they're good they're giving me that
wicked brew it's got wicked ale
yeah wicked ale and hard cider alright
it's called
what the [ __ ] that called guinness
well there's a couple yeah i think it's
called
wicked ale or i think it's called wicked
never angry orchard angry orchard that's
what it is
i like that stuff is that not cool to
like that stuff because it's good i'm
sorry
dj maniac says uh so you do octavio's
flyers huh yes yeah we do uh yes i do so
i just got that right what i posted
those pictures of me being gay as [ __ ]
like i was something off the [ __ ]
ymca like i was [ __ ] out of village
people and [ __ ]
and octave was like man you're looking
good because me and i told you me and
octavia were losing weight around the
same time
yeah that's right and it turns out it
turns out the [ __ ] he knew octavia
from new york
and they're they're going to be meeting
the starry night tonight yeah and i'll
tell you it's like oh yeah of course i
know tom and jim yeah you gotta
understand something man actually well i
mean it's the job scene everybody and
ever if you're in florida yeah you've at
least heard of us like through second
hand yeah mother and like i said she's
like rolled over on her back
and like i said i do a lot of graphic
design for people different bands and
yeah she'll i don't do all of it
obviously but i do a lot of stuff um but
yeah i've done a lot of octavia's stuff
uh you know i did a lot of the starry
night stuff when they were here i did um
i used to do all the memento mori
posters
um what else
i did all the stuff for the grotto when
it was open there's everything you did
in the black metal scene
yeah did someone [ __ ] in the black metal
scene it's nothing funny we can't even
remember all that i can't remember all
the album the covers she made so many
albums i did a sons of ragnar one i
remember that yeah what the [ __ ] else
did i do there's so many [ __ ]
album covers she did in the black metal
scenes and posters too like not just
like for poster shows because like um
we used to have wait is it still there
that bar in winter park what the [ __ ]
was the name of that place the haven
yeah even uh that was kind of near where
my old apartment used to be
and uh they had black metal there pretty
much every friday and saturday i want to
say that was like a monty's thing so
every weekend i was doing like posters
with all of these
bands and their logos and i couldn't
read a single goddamn one of them
because you know how black metal logos
are they all use that same like font and
i'm just like so she sends me all the
logos and i'm like well uh which band is
which because like
i'm such a dork i don't know
that sounder said damn tom remembers
everything those months ago that i said
yeah i remember everything sounder
well
almost it depends
says the guy who's like where are my
glasses like every five seconds
they're on your head i can't get away
with [ __ ] with his [ __ ] around you
can't
because i actually do kind of remember
everything but well mostly i remember
things better than you do though it's
all it's all in good [ __ ] tv you came
back from the mortgage office the other
day and you were flipping out because
you couldn't find your tablet
and you were like well i know i had it
because i had it in the car on the way
back so it's not like he left it like at
the office or whatever and he was like
pissed off and he's like i go in the
bedroom and he's like tear that bed
apart and i was just like dude this is a
you problem not a knee problem
but i did it and i was like look it's
not here i'm like look it's obviously in
the house somewhere did you put it in
the freezer you obviously put it
somewhere you're awesome on top of that
damn thing it fell over into the living
room yeah we have it like the the living
room out there in the hall it's kind of
like it's you know it's a big open room
but it has like an arch and then it has
kind of these like hand rails like hand
rail type things like like walls that
are real low yeah it's almost kind of
like a passover like from a kitchen too
it's like some [ __ ] from a restaurant
yeah or something like that so it has
like a couple things like that so i
guess he had set the tablet on top of
that and it fell off yeah like onto the
carpet on the bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] we
had packed up yeah like a bunch of stuff
that we haven't put up on the walls and
stuff yeah so it just kind of got mixed
in with it
yeah he was flipping out like running
all over [ __ ] piss man
well i'm sitting like i said i was like
what do you want me to do about it i
don't know where the [ __ ] you put the
[ __ ] i was like it's here somewhere
obviously i was at the biker bar to nut
today
i was [ __ ] drinking i got a bunch of
drinks bought for me
and i got to do the show
and then after the show
we we will probably go to mannequins
if i'm not too [ __ ] up because i have
to say
i have not eaten
since
two o'clock yesterday i was gonna cook
something on the way back but she's like
there's not enough well yeah but it was
so late when you got back that it's like
here's the thing i got shipped
i know but here's the thing i can't you
know i can't eat that much otherwise i
will be 400 pounds and i'll be like as
big as a house i'm the same way though
so
when i eat i like to take my time and
enjoy my food because this is probably
like the only food i'm gonna eat all day
right
so the fact that you didn't get back
until like 4 30. you blame me and then
no i'm just saying and then you didn't
come back and then he was like well i
could cook something right now i'm like
yeah but then i'll have to like cram it
in my face and then when we do the show
i have a stomachache because that's what
happens when i eat too fast i get a
stomachache so i was like i don't want
to do the show with a stomachache uh you
know so we're gonna have to wait till
after so i'm actually drinking an empty
stomach i've not eaten for more than 24
hours it's okay once the show's over i
can go down there and whip up something
real quick don't worry about it because
yesterday so many tacos i got corn i got
carnitas i just made yeah he made it
into the crock pot i made a [ __ ] ton of
coconut crackers
now sandra if you know what carnitas are
and that's some [ __ ] that makes in
germany they don't have that's mexican
as [ __ ] carnitas it means like lil
meaties meaties little meats
little meaties
[Laughter]
it's just a meat like wheaties but meat
it's the meat that you use in making
things you've always got to have some
carnitas around so you use it as a
component in making like like a taco or
a burrito or
a sandwich you know something like that
well a taco in a burrito that's a
mexican sandwich
yeah i mean we usually eat it on tacos
but you can like throw it in with like
some spanish rice and eggs and cheese
eggs at work say yeah we've done that
too oh yeah well because usually you do
the whole thing in the crock pot like
overnight and then like we use it we use
it over the next like several days like
in different things it tends to be salt
garlic cloves of garlic
some pepper maybe
and then some cumin
some chili
cocoa powder
that's about it
well
yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] you know
the little stuff like [ __ ] basil not
basil what do you call this [ __ ]
uh the leaves cilantro no
cilantro is towards the end the little
leaves that you use bay leaves
babies
that's where you cook meat in
bay leaves cocoa cinnamon that's good
yeah it's really good and it makes the
whole house smell
amazing yeah the house smells like meaty
and cinnamony yeah
human blood
[Laughter]
what hearts of sacrifice
i mean [ __ ] you want to get really
mexican it's gonna gotta have human
humor yeah
you gotta get aztec we gotta get hashtag
as a [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
saunders uh saunders says dupuki and
beijing go outside now i think beijing i
mean beijing goes outside just like on
the back porch pookie doesn't really
seem interested in going outside
she hasn't even asked yeah she's too
scared to go outside right now um
she looks outside like she looks out the
window but otherwise she doesn't really
seem to care uh she doesn't she mostly
stays on the second floor
and kind of looks out the windows i
don't know if it's just because she
thinks she can't go outside because she
can't fly
or
um if because our neighbors have two
dogs and they bark every time somebody
goes out side like every time i go to
take the garbage out or whatever like
the dogs bark um they seem like nice
dogs they're not mean or anything but um
she's uh she got really scared of dogs
because of that incident that happened
at the old house while i was in saint
augustine
uh of the dog trying to make friends
with her and her like losing her [ __ ]
uh so cj maniac says so you guys make
otavio's flyers yeah we do a lot of
octavius flyers yeah yeah we were
talking about that before
and then david jude says sandra is boba
fett of 13 o'clock unless we know how
cool she is and then [ __ ] senator
goes d damn tom remembers everything
this month ago
um i haven't seen b in a while
he was around on wednesday i think
was he not bee's nest
yeah yeah and i've gotten messages from
from him since then he keeps bothering
me to be like where's tom like tell him
to check his messages
no need for me too says tom's looking
ripped old guy jack yeah i'm [ __ ] old
superman he's old guy i'm old superman
when superman gets old he's me
um
somebody goes uh
tom what do you sheila asked tom what do
you think of the alec baldwin shooting
okay that seemed like
some like uh brandon
leash
where it was like an accident
i was just talking to a friend of mine
in hollywood i'm going to school with i
mean i just read a real quick article
about it so i don't know that much about
it he's doing a western right now with
uh
uh what's girl's name from [ __ ] star
wars from mandalorian gina
yeah you're doing something with gina
right now yeah that's right
um
whatever happened is the armorer's fault
the armorer is the guy who own who has
control over all the the weaponry yeah
it's v
dealing with movie guns is harder
than even dealing with real guns because
when you're dealing with real guns you
know that they're real guns and you know
that it's real ammunition
and you know when you're dealing with
training bikes
with hollywood guns it's a lot harder
because a lot of times you're dealing
with real guns that have been modified
yet to deal with blanks but then there's
dummy ammunition
and dummy ammunition and blanks can
constitute live ammunition
so it's very easy to make a mistake and
get shocked when you're dealing with i'm
just
i mean to be honest i'm surprised it
doesn't happen more often because you
know accidents can happen if you have a
dummy round
a dummy round looks like a live round
but it isn't live
sometimes you can make a dummy round
and
it's a dummy it doesn't it is a real
bullet in a real case without any
[ __ ] powder without a powder charge
in it
but instead of putting a fake primer in
the back
you can put a real primer in the back
and if you put that in a cylinder and a
hammer hits it the primer has enough
[ __ ] power to force a [ __ ]
projectile or a bullet
down into the barrel of a weapon
and it will do it totally silently you
won't even hear a sound nothing
after you unload that revolver
if there was a [ __ ] round that was
defective like that in other words a
a dummy round
that was made with a real primer the
only different you would notice that
maybe you would notice that one of the
bullets was gone
but a lot of people who aren't real who
are actors who aren't familiar with
yeah you wouldn't notice any different
notice and you would probably rely on
yeah you know the weapon specialist
that's on set that's supposed to be like
taking care of that [ __ ] but you know so
now you have a projectile a bullet
lodged halfway down a barrel of a
firearm later on if you put a blank in
that and start shooting it
the blank has enough force to push that
live
or that projectile down that bullet and
get down that barrel and that's what
happened to brandon lee yeah that's
pretty much what happened and this one
it seems like i'm not sure if they're
releasing all the details yet like i
said i just read a really quick article
about it but it seems like from the
article i read they said even if you
know it's a blank
generally they try to stay at least 20
feet away from the actor that you shoot
because even if you shoot somebody like
close up with a blank it's still gonna
like hurt them you know what i mean
which i feel like a lot of people
because we were talking about that
weren't we we were talking about the man
who fell to earth that one scene where
there was just like shooting blanks like
right in each other's faces you must and
i'm like
yeah i don't think that's a good idea
not really not that close they will both
kill you
now brian who's the guy that i went to
school with who's on the chrono flick
they don't ha they don't have all the
details but they're spooked
because he's all
the chrono flick is also at western okay
and
the last that they heard
they don't know all the details yet but
the last that they heard this was a
double-barreled shotgun that this
happened to me
and if that happened that's even worse
because yeah well it killed the
cinematographer and wounded one other
person like on the crew
a double-barreled uh 1800s
double-barreled
[ __ ]
shotgun
is extremely simple
if you [ __ ] that up and somehow
allowed live ammunition
to make its way into
into that weapon
you're going to lose you're you're going
to lose your career
well and probably rightfully so because
i mean it's one thing to like make a
little mistake on the job where
everyone's just kind of like oh that's a
little mistake but you make a mistake
that gets someone killed yeah then yeah
probably not nobody knows the details
yet no like i said i just read something
about it like a couple hours ago like
really quickly so
goodness i don't know what the [ __ ]
going on you're allergic to something
me muscles
the kitty i don't know
badass domain says hey guys are you
watching the new chucky series on tv no
and uh have you seen halloween kills yet
i was just gonna talk about that yes we
watched it yesterday we went to the
theater and we saw it in dolby cause
that's what i was gonna say was that
that was the last time i ate was that
before we went to see halloween kills
we went over to the mall across the
thing and like we ate at the food court
and that was the last time i ate
halloween kills i gotta say i just you
know i was gonna say oh we should save
it for a matinee but
i don't know we'll probably see some
other movies before sunday so it's like
not really that big a deal that is a
pretty solid flick gotta say
okay they're asking about b now b is not
in jail b is free b got sick and had to
[ __ ] recuperate for a couple days but
he's back
so bee's all right he got he got to talk
he got in contact with me yeah he's been
messaging us the last couple days yeah
he's all right that's nothing nothing
really you gotta say
yeah it's [ __ ] happens you know
but yeah so uh but yeah we'll talk about
halloween kills in a minute um i want to
say too that
when we went over to the mall to get
food uh we also went into fye where i
got this like kick-ass shirt um and also
they always see i'm always tempted by
because the fye is right by the food
court so we always like walk by it on
the way to get food and they always have
those really tempting
uh kind of things out front where like
hey like buy one get one free like dvds
or blu-rays or whatever or you know ones
for five dollars and then they had all
the horror [ __ ] in the front so i'm kind
of like well you guys saw me coming but
yeah so i ended up getting not only did
i get this kick-ass shirt
which they had a bunch of these man they
had this creature from the black lagoon
like it was between this one and they
had one of the invisible man and i
really liked that one too but the reason
i got this one you know instead of that
one because i couldn't decide was that
this one they actually had a small
and the
cr uh the invisible male 1 they only had
medium like all the smiles were sold out
so they had a jaws one
they had god they had like a bunch of
other movies but yeah they were all
really cool but look okay so i got a
blu-ray of the original
amityville horror
which i didn't have surprisingly enough
also got a blu-ray of the original
carrie look at that [ __ ] cover i love
that so much but yeah got that which
amazingly enough i didn't have this is a
good buy i think it was like 15-20 bucks
yeah and then like dvds they had house
with a clock in its walls which you guys
i had to get this because we saw this in
the theater
this is one of the books this is my
favorite book from childhood
um by john bel airs it's a good movie
and uh and i was and even like years and
years ago i was like why didn't some
[ __ ] make this into a movie it's such
a good book
um and it had edward gory illustrations
like when it came out back in the 70s
and i've reread it like a zillion times
and it's still good like as an adult and
they finally made it into a movie and it
was awesome i was like thinking that it
was gonna be it's a jack black movie
yeah
i know yeah he plays like the wizard or
whatever and i also got uh night of
living dead the tom savini one like from
1990 because i didn't have that one
obviously i have the original yeah this
one's uh actually like much better than
i haven't seen in a while but i remember
this being like pretty [ __ ] good it's
good you know it's thompson
i did not like thompson
dj maniac says i said the porno version
the house with the [ __ ] in the balls
[Laughter]
that gave me a really funny mental image
just then
danny rolling ghostface says i hate how
they act like halloween h2o never
happens in these new halloween films
yeah see that's the thing we were
talking about that on the car on the way
home i said because in some ways
the the newer movies like halloween 2018
and this new hot like hollywood kills
they basically just go all the way back
to halloween two right yeah and be like
okay all that [ __ ] that happened in in
there we just we're just la la la
we're just pretending that didn't exist
which that's okay yeah actually this new
halloween movie i liked it i liked it
better than the 18 than the two i did as
well it wasn't bad it was good um i just
and you know it's a good score it's
always nice to see anthony michael hall
in something i didn't realize that see
somebody essentially the main character
yes gotta say essentially anthony
michael hall carries this movie
he's the dude who's oh thank you victor
thank you very much hey i'm off today i
missed y'all hey we miss you too thank
you so much anthony michael hall
okay
hunky is as that [ __ ] was back
in the damn dead zone [ __ ]
movie series very hunky guy still look
still look very good for his age
um and he was he was playing the dude
that was
fomenting and whipping up the lynch mob
to go out and [ __ ] kill michael myers
well he was playing is this a spoiler to
say this he's playing
the grown-up version of tommy doyle the
little kid from the first movie that
jamie lee curtis was babysitting it's
worth it's worth seeing i mean the gore
was uh was pretty damn good pretty good
it's worth seeing yeah and like he said
i liked it better than honestly and we
were talking about this maybe and i
don't know if this is spoilery it's a
spoilery
um i kind of feel like
i like that they did with this second
one
almost what they did with the original
halloween 2 where it's like let's it's
and i'm sure they did this on purpose
we're gonna make this whole movie where
jamie lee curtis is essentially like in
the hospital like
pretty much the whole time just like
they kind of did in halloween too
and then they also had a reference in
there to the silver shamrock masks
so i was like i wonder if they make
another one will they be
are they going to like do a crossover
with like michael myers and
the silver shamrock
if they don't i mean they ought to it
seemed like they were building up to
that i i kind of hope they do they don't
they [ __ ] suck ass
[Laughter]
my
i didn't see halloween one and two as a
kid i saw halloween three that was the
first [ __ ] halloween movie i saw i
[ __ ] loved it so i didn't have any
preconceived notions
and to this day actually out of the
halloween series
i like halloween three the best
but halloween three
and the masks and the [ __ ] dude with
the [ __ ] magic
rock dust that came out of [ __ ] the
stonehenge stonehenge and all this
[ __ ] irish [ __ ]
death magic and [ __ ]
i [ __ ] like that [ __ ] and if they
come out with halloween three
a silver shamrock [ __ ] and they
tie in michael myers
because they set it up they set it up in
this this last minute i kind of feel
like they did yeah like not overtly but
i think they did kind of like it they
were going jamie there curtis says no
mortal man could ever have survived what
this dude has been through all right
this is something about pure hatred and
[ __ ]
and that's they're talking about like
the dark side of the force and then they
keep showing these goddamn masks these
silver shamrock masks well some of the
victims have a mom yeah
so you're like well wait a minute
did the dude who owned the silver
shamrock company knows something about
hatred and being able to [ __ ]
you know i mean go beyond what was
humanly possible you know basically
you're talking it
it's the force just the dark side of the
forest is what they're talking about so
michael myers is a sith michael myers
sith demon that's not as cool somehow
well you're looking at it from a star
wars point of view but i would i would
be i would downplay a little bit that's
what they're talking about is that well
i mean at this point [ __ ] you're
almost magic he's like transcending
you're transcending what's normal what's
normal right and it might have something
to do with stonehenge and the druids
and here's the
thing ai
robots are now a possibility so the
silver shamrock [ __ ] story makes more
sense now when you got an evil corporate
[ __ ]
with robots
okay with androids that are killing
people
all right
and trying to get hold of these magic
[ __ ] rocks that are [ __ ] infused
with dark side powers yeah it started if
you did it right
it would be great i mean you'd really
have to be careful though because i do
kind of feel like halloween
i want to say five and six did it start
in five where they were starting to go
in the supernatural direction it is
supernatural um but yeah but like i said
i think they even hinted that in the
first [ __ ] movie because it's like
obviously loomis shoots him at the end
of the first one spoiler alert from
1978. um and then like they look out and
they're like oh [ __ ] he's gone so
i mean it's kind of like well i mean you
could say the same thing about jason
which uh you know the friday 13th maybe
which also went off in ridiculous
directions because
what's scary
what's scary about a stalker that you
know it chops up a bunch of teenagers
and then you shoot him and he's dead
like a normal person it's like way
scarier if you can like get back up and
it's and i think it's honestly i think
it's way scarier if it's not completely
explained either
like if you don't really know so in some
ways i'm kind of like we were talking
about this on the car on the way home i
said i would like it actually if they
did
almost like a new trilogy like the first
three halloweens and they kind of went
i'm not saying they should make the next
one like without michael myers and
they're just like just throw you a
curveball that's just like all about
silver shamrock but if they could do
like a crossover with that in a way that
wasn't stupid as hell
i mean it could be done
um
but without over explaining
because see and and i've brought this up
before this is why i did not like
rob zombie's take on halloween because
he over explained the [ __ ] over explain
oh michael myers just a poor abused kid
nobody wants to hear that you gotta
leave [ __ ] hanging now come on your
imagination has to work scarier when you
don't know mystery is always scarier
which you would think that like horror
people would know that by now well
they don't
um but i i i liked the movie
um
i really do hope that to me it looked
like they were trying to tie this
the silver shamrock angle into it and i
hope they do
if they [ __ ]
if they blow that off i think they're
really
they're really screwing the pooch i mean
you have
you're already dealing with a trilogy
now so you might as well include that
and like i said they really did seem to
do like a halloween two
it i mean this movie wasn't like exactly
like halloween two
but they did the same thing like i said
with jamie lee curtis being in the
hospital most of the time and they did
the same thing where
this movie is set only an hour or two
after the events of halloween 2018 which
is the same thing that they did with the
original halloween and halloween two
which was set on like the same night
and so
i mean obviously they did that on
purpose
so i'm kind of thinking i wonder what
they're going to do with the next one
now so now i'm like intrigued yeah
tila's here what's up taylor what you
doing
yeah tila said uh h2o is really good
well acted but michael's mask is off
though honestly i think i saw h2o in the
theater when it came out and i remember
liking it being like ah that was pretty
good um but then i can't really remember
a single thing wasn't busta rhymes in
that i feel like buster rhymes within
that
and then like i but i can't remember
hardly a single thing that happened
today
but i remember it being okay at the time
um i think i've seen them all at some
point or another but i don't like when
it started going supernatural like into
the what's the [ __ ] wasn't it like a
cult or like the thorn something or
whatever um
after it kind of went off in that
direction i don't even like remember
what the [ __ ] lore was after after we
got done seeing uh
halloween this new halloween how many
kills
um
it kind of hit me again
what what a disappointment
that uh [ __ ] um
uh what was that that we just saw
[ __ ] uh wait you said candy man
candyman candyman too
they could have done so much better
and after the after seeing caddy man it
[ __ ]
it hit me how much that movie depends on
oh boy
[ __ ]
tony todd yeah
well i was going to say that you know
because when i saw todd i was like oh
yeah yeah this is it this is it now it's
back and then it ended
i was like ah
danny rolling ghost face talking about
halloween kills when those little kids
psyched out the gay couple was funny as
[ __ ] here's the thing i liked those
characters actually yeah
everybody gets killed i was telling i
was i was saying this to jenny it's not
a spoiler it's a slasher movie
now
nowadays the way hollywood is
they always got to have
a diverse cast with a bunch of
representation from the lgbt and to me
the [ __ ] always looks fake as [ __ ] all
right just the way the story unfolds
you're like you know what they're doing
it it's like formula it's like a formula
but with this one it felt very um
organic i feel very organic
um kind of like the way predator one
has a very diverse cast it's all dudes
but they're all very diverse it felt
organic because it was right for the
that's the way the military is so that's
where mercenaries are and you're like
yeah this is the way it really just felt
very natural and i must say that in this
one it felt very natural
when they introduced the gay characters
it felt natural
um
there was some stereotypes there but i
was like hey
there's a lot of truth in stereotyping
the [ __ ] knew how to decorate
okay gay men know how to decorate
weirdly like
big john looks weirdly to me i don't
know maybe this is just me but he looks
weirdly like rufus wainwright yeah they
had the place decorated some of the
walls were black and dark green i was
into their decorating i'm like looking
around the house going man this place
looks fantastic you're a boat named john
you had big john a little john a little
john was a big guy and big john was a
little guy and [ __ ] then i loved
those two yeah i wanted them to live but
yeah you had kind of a [ __ ]
guy and a masculine guy and
they were going to fight michael myers
they both got killed that was another
thing like i said everybody gets yeah
they did that in a couple different ways
where they were dealing with opera since
you had a you had a black couple to
where you had well they were in
halloween costumes they were in
halloween costumes the woman
was dressed as a nurse and the man said
there's a man but she was a
doctor and he was a nurse so they they
kind of flipped it around
and uh they did some cool [ __ ] and you
thought she was gonna [ __ ]
kill michael myers with a [ __ ] 50
caliber desert eagle [ __ ] a 50 ae
50 action express desert eagle
and man she went down bad but
there the movie was always getting
giving you hope
like hey maybe this is going to be like
the main character
[Laughter]
i liked that though it was
green
okay we're back
lost connection are we back yeah see
this is what is bothering me
and i can't and i don't have the phone
to back up on because i've used all my
data for the month yeah so i don't have
a phone as backup until november 1st so
i'm kind of now this is just the regular
this is our regular [ __ ] uh community
network right here
yeah this is just our regular it's good
this is through the cable okay yeah it's
got one now all right
but uh
yeah yeah tila said i felt bad for the
mentally ill dude who they were chasing
horrible death scene yeah it's a lot of
the kills in this were really really
brutal you can tell that they really
lean
yeah you could tell they really leaned
into that r rating yeah uh because they
were like so happy they seemed that was
one thing that occurred to me while i
was watching it i was like they're
obviously so gleeful that this was rated
r because everyone was [ __ ] this and
[ __ ] that and [ __ ] and [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and then um and then the
gore was just kind of like off the chain
like pretty much but yeah yes it's i
guess it was nice because i'm so used to
seeing like pg-13 horror movies where
they kind of have to go oh let's not
look at the gore but this one was like
pretty gory so i gotta say what i did
like about it is that anthony michael
hall did a really good job in it um he's
uh he was he was real good in it it um
it was entertaining there was a couple i
think i would i remember saying that
after we got done with the movie that
you thought it could have been a little
bit shorter yeah it could have been a
bit shorter it's an hour and 45 minutes
it needed a tighter edit
but they left some stuff in there they
were trying to do
characterization
and the reason why they did that is
you're trying to differentiate to make
sure that you know this is not friday
the 13th
because
halloween is supposed to be a little bit
deeper than friday the 13th
i kind of disagree
no
13th friday the 13th was a ripoff of
halloween yeah they're very similar i
think i think i probably would i think i
probably would have cut a lot of that
[ __ ] out and kept it [ __ ] uh
a lot basically action horror movie and
i would have left it as a friday the
13th but to be honest to me it really
didn't seem like there was a lot of like
too much characterization going on and
honestly um i you know i liked a lot of
the characters which actually you don't
really see a lot in horror movies and
you definitely don't see them for the
13th movies uh because friday 13th
movies you're just like yeah look at all
these annoying [ __ ] just kill
him but this one like some of the people
i was like didn't really want to see him
get killed and then i was just like ah
you know what i mean
but that's good though we kind of have
to be honest though
[ __ ]
what's her name didn't have to be in
this damn movie
but well like i was saying before one
there
what's
[Music]
they're making an homage to halloween
too i think right and two and i was
telling you this before like in a way it
seems more realistic to me because if
they had made it because like at the end
of halloween 2018 she got like her
[ __ ] like stomach all stabbed and her
like her guts were hanging out so it's
kind of like
um
if she had been able to like just jump
out the hospital bed and like kick ass
after that like for the whole movie yeah
i'm just gonna go get him and [ __ ] like
that everybody'd be like now that's not
what would really happen so i kind of
liked that they went like a more
realistic route with that and she's in
it a lot it's like she's in scenes and
stuff it's just that she's not like out
there like it kind of like goes to a lot
of other characters and like i said i
really like i didn't i actually didn't
even know that anthony michael hall was
in this so i was like i didn't know he
was in it yeah i like that dude
and i'm like oh all right yeah isn't it
hilarious to think that like this that's
the same dude from the breakfast club
yeah what tina's saying you played a
long time yeah well what happened with
that like he always played like the the
dork like and we see he was in the
breakfast club and uh weird science and
stuff and then like edward scissorhands
came out and he's suddenly like almost
unrecognizable because he's like this
big bulked-up football player type dude
and everyone was like what the [ __ ] yeah
like i think we talked about a little
bit when we did that
yeah if
if you liked this you should see the
television series you can buy it or rent
it
off of [ __ ] amazon
the dead zone
yeah they did like a series of the
deputy when was that i have it 2000 like
mid 2000's i want to say i think it was
mid tuesday i have it on dvd me and
jenny watched it it's really good it's
really good i really liked it a lot it's
a series based upon stephen king story
of the dead zone anthony michael hall's
starting it starring in it
as johnny as johnny and [ __ ] he
he looked good man he's very hunky type
dude
um
to me it's obvious that he did a couple
cycles of anabolics and [ __ ] got big
but um
no great show
great show yeah that was like that show
was way better than i was expecting yeah
for for not having heard that much about
it you're right or even at the time
maybe i just wasn't paying attention
uh thank you victor i told y'all to get
a hot spot with unlimited data well i do
have a mobile hotspot on my phone
and in
theory it has unlimited data
but in practice
it only goes up to a certain amount and
then it's like now i'm going to charge
you even more than 70 and i can't afford
that [ __ ] start tethered to you i would
kill that one and just go off off the
off the one we're using now that's all
you need
well no because i like to have the
backup and honestly i was running out of
data what about what about what's hugh's
net well yeah i gotta i gotta do that
too but i know i'm talking about my
phone i'm not talking about he's dead um
but
what i was gonna say was i actually like
having the unlimited data on my phone
because i was running out
uh before because yeah i was going to
the cheap plan because like i said you
know i don't have a [ __ ] ton of money so
uh thank you mr roboto will you be
decorating for halloween and giving
candy
yeah we probably will i wonder if
there's any like going to be any
trick-or-treaters around here
i mean i hear kids and that's i see
school buses coming through here so i
guess there's i haven't really seen and
a lot of people around here do seem to
have decorated for halloween so that's
something even though like i said the
houses are farther apart so i don't know
how common trick-or-treating is here
in our old neighborhood it's weird
because
it was kind of like one or the other
like we would get like a [ __ ] ton of
candy it's i guess this happens to
everybody but you get like a you know
one year
we'd run out of candy because it was
like 40 bajillion
children and then so the next year be
like oh my god we have to get like all
this extra candy and then we'd have like
three people
so i don't really know
i don't know i guess it depends like
what night it was on and stuff but maybe
since it's sunday night now i kind of
feel like now people are gonna like kids
are gonna be trick-or-treating on
saturday night so [ __ ] man i don't know
i don't know i don't know what we're
gonna do and honestly
because halloween's on a sunday and we
usually do like a matinee on a sunday so
maybe we'll do like a halloween special
or something like that although i have
to think of a new costume now
because i already did my
dia de los muertos
uh
outfit that was from mento
and then i already did a bride of
frankenstein that was for halfway to
halloween and i think i was already on
camera as that
so then last night i was like [ __ ] man
what like
what costume can i get real quick like
like
without having to like spend a [ __ ] ton
of money i was like i think the only
thing that i can do i can do wednesday
adam so that i have to buy anything but
that seems like really lazy so i don't
know we'll see what i can do i'll think
of something maybe hey pokey she's
laying over there
she's laying over sleeping but yeah i i
don't know it's like i'm always really
just like everything else in my life i
always like overthink
halloween costumes
and i can't ever if i'm gonna do
halloween costumes i really don't want
to like half-ass it i want it to be like
really really good
um so
and i always want to do something kind
of original you know what i mean but
it's sometimes it's like hard to think
of something
you guys should totally review freddy
versus jason i saw freddy versus jason
in the theater some time ago yeah i
remember it being pretty fun i don't
remember like what happens in it really
i remember like the end of it
like with the freddy's head like winking
and stuff but
i don't really remember much of it other
than that
tila said we rarely get uh
trick-or-treaters we live in condo
complex mostly young couples and singles
are retirees
yeah i'm just like i don't
mr roboto said no elvira costume i
actually did think about that was one of
the ones
uh because i probably
i probably have an outfit that could
like approximate that
i don't have hair like hers but i could
probably like you guys you got a wig i
have a wig i mean i have a blonde or a
black wig that i could probably sandra
said she just watched edward
scissorhands after our review yeah it's
much more sad than she remembered it is
very sad it is a very sad movie
tammy said that's one thing i miss
living in the middle of nowhere we get
no trick-or-treaters
i wonder if we're going to get into here
i mean
i'm sure we will like i said i know
there's kids in the neighborhood because
i can hear them like coming off the
school bus
but and people do have decorated for
halloween over here
we honestly
we have um
we have like the lazy halloween
decorations
just the projectors the projector lights
we have like the bats and we have bats
and ghosts right we have a bat one and a
ghost one that's that one's purple and
this one's white
and uh we used to at the old house we
used to project them on the clot on the
um garage doors
but this house
do we even have an outside power source
no but i can run it out through the
garage because i looked around at our
old house we had like plugs outside yeah
but this house i haven't like found any
unless they hit them behind the bushes
or something so we haven't actually put
them out yet another thing that's been
interesting lately is dune
oh my god thank you so much john
robertson oh [ __ ] what was that hey guys
just watched halloween kills this has to
be the most brutal i've seen myers a
long time the kills were brutal yeah i
agree they actually did a good job with
like the [ __ ] killings on that one
they were kind of pretty [ __ ] up they
were almost uh all disturbing to me i
always thought about myers being like a
force of nature and embodiment of evil
yeah and i think that's kind of like the
direction they're going with it so
hopefully but yeah like i said i'm
really happy that they really leaned
into that r rating gotta say oh and
another thing i was going to say too was
that one of the previews that we saw i
didn't i hadn't even heard about this
until now they're doing another scream
movie
it's not a reboot because it's got all
the characters it's got like sequels
it's like sydney and dewey and all of
them
they're all in it but it's like a new
generation and much like halloween 2018
they're just calling this one scream
yeah look good
it actually it actually did look pretty
good yeah i don't remember i know i saw
the first scream obviously i've seen
that one several times um
i'm pretty sure i saw the second one and
that was pretty good and i think they
made a third and a fourth
um and i might have seen those but i
don't know we'll see it yeah it looks
pretty good the soho movie look good i
can't wait to see that that looks
awesome it looks good that looks awesome
and and dune
yeah yeah everybody's saying dune is
fantastic
um connor botzlon who's a subscriber and
always comment and hear a friend of mine
he uh
living in mexico he got a early hd
bootleg
of it like two days ago
he said it was great he loved it his
wife didn't like it that much she said
it was kind of a man's flick according
to her
but uh what does that even mean i don't
know
i don't think she grew up with the lore
or read the book
but people who know the book and the the
first movie liked it
so i'm excited about it that's playing
tonight i think in it here i think it
starts tonight um you know and then wide
release tomorrow right and like i said
so we got to see that sometime this
weekend or monday or whatever and then
tuesday night we got to do riff tracks
live
right uh their halloween special they're
doing amityville four yeah which i'm
saying i'm a huge fan of the book and
the movie i like them both
well and it's nice that somebody's
actually like gonna do it
justice maybe i mean you know obviously
david lynch did it but they did they
[ __ ] around with his stuff so much
that
dune can't be a single movie that's not
movable it has to be a trilogy
or two movies
yeah i mean the book is like so
intricate right that
uh tila says looking forward to dune and
antlers yeah i can't wait to see antlers
i think that's coming out when october
29th i want to say just like the weekend
the week yeah like right before
halloween so i'm excited about that i've
been wanting to see i've been seeing
trailers for that [ __ ] since like
[ __ ] last year
so as far as dune goes everybody that i
can trust is saying it's [ __ ] awesome
so i'm i'm jacked for [ __ ] dune
i can't wait yeah we will definitely see
it in the next few days if not this
weekend then monday i'm glad i have
lived as long as i have lived
trilogy come to [ __ ] the screen
yeah it's gonna be good i was trying to
think of some of the other trailers that
we saw what was that other one like
blumhouse movie
there's a new horror movie from
blumhouse coming out yeah it looked all
right but bluehouse movies are on the
black phone yeah
that actually looks pretty decent yeah
it looks like it's a throwback like it's
set in the 70s it looked like it was set
in the 70s about a kid that gets
kidnapped and it looked like [ __ ] uh
ethan hawk was in it
there's another channel that i listened
to it's called midnight's edge and they
got some guys that come from they're
kind of behind the scenes hollywood
studio guys they got kicked out and
they're they're kind of they'll tell you
everything that's going on in these
studios and how they worked
they're cut out of the loop but they
still have a lot of friends are still in
there
and they've been saying that the past
couple years the movies that we're
getting are kind of [ __ ] up
because they were made like four years
ago
and that now we're gonna start getting a
new
batch of movies that are more like crowd
pleasers
more like getting asses into seats type
of movies
so i'm hoping that
movies will be better than they have
been in the past couple years and that's
what that's what guys from
midnight's edge are saying so let's hope
that let's hope that's true
because a lot of [ __ ] is mediocre a lot
well i mean that's kind of true of all
eras though and the thing about it is
that
you know uh you don't really have the
benefit like [ __ ] that's coming out
nowadays you don't have the benefit of
hindsight it's like what's gonna like
survive and all these other movies are
just gonna be forgotten about which like
i said is kind of what happened through
the 80s that's why so many people
remember so many movies fondly from the
80s because only the ones that were
awesome
those are the ones that everybody still
remembers
all the other ones just
yeah but there is there is something
like i'm gonna say to that though
the 80s was a backlash to the [ __ ]
failures of the 70s they did have some
good 70s movies but most of them weren't
very good
um the 80s was kind of a backlash to
that
and the best
directors of the 80s were indie guys
that the studios had so in some cases
kind of picked up
which would be uh steven spielberg
george lucas
those kind of guys and it's because you
know
60 in the 60s the studios were pretty
[ __ ] up i mean they only wanted to
make westerns
or cop movies
yeah
basically
well it's just like i said it's it's a
business where and it's kind of always
been like this
because you're investing so much money
in an intellectual property
they're really really like risk-averse
right and like so if something comes out
that's a huge success everybody's
immediately like well let's rip that off
or let's do something like that
so
and like i said you can understand why
they do that because it's not like
they're not gonna like pour millions of
dollars into some director or some idea
that they think it just isn't going to
fly because they don't know ultimately
like what the public is interested in
studios that are kind of the last ones
on the on to the game it's it's
everybody else that's kind of ahead of
the curve
like for instance
there were movies that i saw in the 80s
that i [ __ ] liked they weren't quite
there one of them was like [ __ ] um
what was it galaxy of terror
i like that that was the roger corman
roger corman galaxy of terror
and it was an alien rip-off but it was
better
the director or not i don't think it was
the director what was it was the the
science the
special effects guy behind a lot of that
was um
james cameron yeah
well roger corman gave a lot of like big
hollywood heavy hitters there yeah
and with that and when i saw a [ __ ]
galaxy of terror i was like man there's
something to this i love this movie that
chick got raped by a goddamn caterpillar
a giant so slimy and then [ __ ] and
then that dude a [ __ ] crystal jumped
up into his arm and went up and killed
him that was sid hey yeah
and uh i [ __ ]
it wasn't the greatest movie but i knew
there was something there
well from that that's where alien aliens
or alien 2 came from that and terminator
1 came from that those movies wouldn't
have happened without galaxy of terror
yeah
and
we're in that galaxy of terror
time i think now
where
shit's gonna change out
that's just that's just my opinion
and they missed a lot of [ __ ]
like i [ __ ] loved elita battle angel
i thought there should have been a
sequel to that
everybody i know liked that movie i
[ __ ] i own it on blu-ray watch that
[ __ ] all day long there should have been
another battle angel after that
well they might eventually yeah yeah
rosario what's her name rosario
dawson no
is that her name
not that no rosa salazar salazar how did
i pull that out of my ass holy crap
yeah it was a good movie
yeah another one i'm gonna have to agree
with mango on this mango says uh i would
have to disagree with that about the 70s
movies films the 80s was worse but it
did have some good ones and most of the
80s movies came about in the 70s yeah i
kind of feel like most of my honestly as
far as horror goes i kind of feel like
the 70s is my favorite horror decade
although i like horror movies from every
decade
um 80s was kind of more like slasher
horror comedy which like that's fine
um but i kind of feel i like 70s because
it was more like a crap shoot like it
was kind of more arty party in the 80s
everything went more toward and i love
like a lot of movies from the 80s
obviously but in the 80s it did go more
toward like you know more big epic like
crowd pleasing kind of stuff or like i
said in horror went more towards slasher
or comedy um which is fine but
i don't know if i had to pick a favorite
decade at least for horror movies i
would uh yeah pick the 70s i don't know
some 70s movies were actually 80s movies
they were kind of [ __ ] you know i
mean they were ahead of their time like
alien 1 was the 80s movie well that was
very late 70s that was 1979. i don't
know exactly what you're talking about
you know i mean like yeah you had
you had um
um
[ __ ] exorcist that was a 70s movie
yeah 73 yeah 73 but you know and then
there was a lot of really good 70 movies
carrie 1976
but they weren't all good
and a lot of those
movies if you actually analyze them
they're kind of like more something from
the 80s suspiria in 1977 yeah
bay of blood 1970 there wasn't that many
of them
most 70s movies were [ __ ] westerns
i don't know i like a lot of movies i
like a lot of 70s horror movies bad
westerns on tv changeling although that
was 1980
but that's just right on the cusp yeah
so that was okay but yeah i mean there
was a lot of seven there was a lot of
80s [ __ ] though too there was well yeah
i remember i was there
well like i said that's kind of why we
have the benefit of hindsight we grew up
during the 70s and 80s um so i remember
that not only in movies but also in
music and stuff like that like a lot of
the [ __ ] sucked it wasn't good
um you know what i mean and the only
reason like people look back on it
fondly is that you only remember the
good [ __ ] or you weren't alive back then
so you didn't have to experience all the
crap like all the noise that was going
on around the good [ __ ] you know what i
mean but that's like i said that's kind
of true of every era only the only the
best [ __ ] like survives to get picked up
by subsequent generations and if you
didn't live through that era then
you know you obviously you wouldn't
realize that there was like just a ton
of other crap that just got forgotten
about yeah so yeah texas chainsaw
massacre somebody brings up also the
omen yep
phantasm
a lot of the 80s stuff though was trying
to hearken back to the good 70s though
they were trying to bring that although
like i said as much as i love slasher
movies i do kind of feel like the 80s
was kind of dominated by slasher movies
at least in the horror genre and that's
not entirely true there was like some
cool [ __ ] going on there a lot of them a
lot of them second rate too yeah well
like i said because halloween which was
1978 uh was such a massive success on
such a small budget yeah um you know
immediately sean cunningham who the dude
that did uh friday the 13th was like hey
let's rip that off and he's even said
that like right those are the words that
he uses hey let's rip that off so
i mean you know they obviously the
people had made slashers before that
like i said back in italy they were
making jala movies and mario baba made
bay of blood which was i would argue was
kind of like the first slasher movie i
mean i guess you could argue that psycho
is the first slasher movie or peeping
tom but psycho was not a slasher see
yeah i think psycho is more like a
psychological
i mean i get where they're coming from
but i but if you're gonna say the first
slasher movie that people would
recognize as a slasher movie bay of
blood and that was an italian movie uh
because that was straight up a slasher
movie and it had a lot of the [ __ ] that
later slasher movies would have like it
had the killer pov it had all this other
kind of stuff even though it didn't have
just one killer and it was kind of more
like a mystery type thing but it
absolutely had like a lot of the troops
that people would later recognize as a
slasher movie and if and i think if
anybody that was into slasher movies
from the 80s watched that they would
think that that was a slasher movie and
that came out in like like i said in
1971.
so and then they did black christmas
that was 74 which was very clearly a
slasher movie and that was canadian so
you know
so halloween obviously wasn't the first
slasher movie it was just the one that
popularized the genre because it was so
beloved and so widespread and that's
what made everybody want to rip it off
so during the 80s everybody's like we
have to make a slasher movie because
obviously they're super cheap
just like later on when everybody got
into zombies and zombie movies are super
cheap to make all you needs like a run
down building and like slap some [ __ ]
blood and [ __ ] on people and get them to
shamble around
and bingo you got a zombie movie and
it's like if you want to go even cheaper
just make it a found footage zombie
movie then you can shoot it with a
[ __ ]
you shoot it with a [ __ ] phone you
know what i mean yep but uh yeah you
know
i might need another drink in a minute
you got something in there
well not really
maybe something a bit
yeah black christmas was a good 70s i
still love black christmas honestly and
i just again i feel like it doesn't get
enough credit when people are talking
about you know when people are talking
about slashers i know that halloween is
the big one because like i said
everybody that was kind of the most
widespread one and that was the one that
popularized it but that wasn't the first
one it's just kind of like the whole
found footage thing
everybody talks about blair witch
but i was like did you guys not see
cannibal holocaust because that was
totally a found footage movie um but i
guess more people didn't see that one so
you know
there's a difference between we were the
first one to do it and we're the one
that popularized it thank you mr roboto
attack of the killer tomatoes and basket
case films we just did basket case
didn't we yeah not too long ago good old
frank hennen lotter he also made
frankenhooker and we also uh we did that
one too didn't we man i love
frankenhooker
and i think i said that on the review
too i'm like i i'm not even being ironic
i generally genuinely love that movie
there's just something really like
charming about it
[Laughter]
uh and then october 8th says i love
funhouse yeah i think we talked about
that one too that's toby hooper yeah and
i kind of feel like yeah that doesn't
get like a lot of love either toby
hooper made some good good [ __ ] he made
that he made life force
you know he wasn't just texas chainsaw
massacre gang i was living on a fun
house before i even knew who any of
these people were yeah and i mean it was
like oh that's [ __ ] badass flick
i mean there's something creepy about
carnivals i mean i i guess it's why
there's so many horror movies with
[ __ ] clowns in them even though i
personally don't think
in clowns fun house
and we will see
that guy i have a [ __ ] dad's dad out
there with like a microphone dad's dad
yeah and he was just like you could tell
he was just like so over it in the fog
house
well when i was growing up
i mean that was if when you went to like
these carnivals and [ __ ]
um which in daytona they had it every
like every october they'd do oktoberfest
right so all the carnies would come and
they'd set the [ __ ] up in
the vacant lot next to the drive-in
and uh you know for like a week or
something and you'd go there
and it's it always bummed me out because
i'd seen it in movies
our oktoberfest didn't have a fun house
and i kept it had like the gravatron and
had all that kind of [ __ ] i guess by
that point even by like the 70s and
early 80s i guess the fun house was kind
of like passe
you know what i mean yeah
um you know people didn't really just
want to ride through this little thing
and have like rubber skeletons jumping
out at you
but i don't know i always really like
that they're not scary but strong dog 78
says second um i love how halloween
kills had that they kind of replicated
the 70s movie in a way yeah yeah
especially with like remember the
beginning when with the soundtrack yeah
like the credits and the credits and
then they had the [ __ ] the flaming
jack-o-lanterns
yeah i quite liked that actually yeah
and i was like man [ __ ] it had a
carpenter's [ __ ] score playing
i don't know if carpenter executed that
but he should have well uh john
carpenter was an executive producer on
it um so i'm assuming he had some say
that sounded right it sounded really
good yeah
victor's asking uh did any of you all
remember the pit oh my god
um i think they added that to shutter
not too long i've seen it
and i've also seen like the brandon ten
old one that one
what a weird [ __ ] movie that was that
was like that weird horrible child that
found those little
creatures in that pit in his backyard
and was like feeding them meat and stuff
that's a weird [ __ ] movie
what did he call them trollologs or
something
i don't know [ __ ] man we could we should
do like a retrospective on that that
movie is like so messed up
it's kind of not to be confused with the
gate
even though i kind of feel like the the
little monsters sort of look the same
not the same but similar
um
let's see camp guy says there's a museum
in the georgia state capitol that has
all kinds of weird agricultural
specimens two-headed calves three-tailed
snakes etc creeped me out back in the
day see i love that kind of stuff i love
that kind of stuff
lewis thompson i woke up drunk well
that's always nice
i've been there today's my birthday well
happy birthday 13 o'clock is playing
okay well it's it's a good day so far
hopefully it gets better yeah i'm gonna
give you some of this because i can't
drink it all okay well you've been
drinking all day hanging out with your
biker buddies yeah
i can't believe like you ride around
your motorcycle like [ __ ] dude what
are you doing man i'm just doing what i
do
there you go i told you big well because
like i said you didn't get back to 4 30.
i'm like is he dead somewhere where
i'm good now what do i do i'm hungry
though i'm looking at pookie going what
are we going to do
[Laughter]
well that's your fault
that's your fault
yeah troll yeah i thought he called him
like trollologs or
something and it wasn't there some weird
[ __ ] where he was like
i haven't seen in a long time but wasn't
there some [ __ ] with what
what's she doing i can't see you i can't
see because look at her
is she on her back oh yeah but when you
point at her doing it she's like what
i'm not saying did you punish you don't
point at me don't point at me i'm not
doing anything weird stop it
tom and his biker buddies yeah tom was
drinking before the show yeah yeah yeah
oh hell yeah he decided this morning
because he's drinking like one
well yeah because you left it like but
it was before noon yeah no like out on a
motorcycle ride yeah i'm pretty sure it
was before noon or it was right around
noon 12 30.
and uh
and i figured oh he's gonna go up to
that biker barney and like hang and hang
out all day like talk about bikes with
the dudes yeah
and then he's like well i should go up
there well so i probably should one day
but i said i'm gonna be standing there
for four hours while y'all just like
talking about motorcycles and i'm just
going to be over there going
it's going to be like they'll just tell
you to pull your titties out that's what
they're gonna say they're gonna say okay
pull those out let's see them that's
something
so now i really don't want to go
no thanks
no thanks
no they won't
no i mean i'll just i'll draw like i'll
take a marker and put [ __ ] off on it
[Laughter]
they would just laugh
or just like make them look all like
[ __ ] or or i'll do some makeup on
them and make them look like all
deformed and [ __ ] that would be funnier
nah you don't understand
they would love it when no matter what
it is they would go like oh yeah yeah
yeah
we're that desperate yeah
it is not a
it's not a [ __ ] um
judgmental [ __ ] crowd
[Laughter]
uh to be fair jenny you'd be drunk i
probably would um honestly yeah if they
just like kept on talking about
motorcycles the whole time i'd be like
can i have more
alcohol please then i would just like be
over there just drinking a drink they
would just be giving you money and
telling you to put it in the jukebox
okay so
did you see
what was the selection of the jukebox oh
it's all kinds of shades i'm genuinely
the jukebox the jukebox selection is
online
well yeah i mean it's the 21st century
21st century even like scuzzy biker bars
are in the 21st century that's how far
into this
hey man i [ __ ] i got them playing a
bunch of eddie uh [ __ ] billy idol
we'll see there you go [ __ ] dude oh
yeah yeah white wedding white wedding
it's a nice day for white wedding they
were doing flesh for fantasy old dude
was like yeah i remember everybody did
flesh for fantasy yeah yeah as long as
it's not molly hatchet or no leonard
skinner they have that oh no they were
playing lettuce oh i'm sure yeah i'm
sure free bird and [ __ ]
don't they ever get sick of that song no
holy crap no
they don't have that good greater taste
[Laughter]
they're showing the [ __ ] and they go oh
yeah yeah i remember that one
well i mean the thing about it is that
like [ __ ] from the 80s yeah is classic
rock classic rock now so well i should
even ship from the 90s is classic rock
because
because i went through i mean i don't
listen to the classic rock stations so
much but when uh where i used to work
that was the only station anybody would
tolerate yeah um
and so there's like a slow progression
of you know yeah it's all leonard
skynyrd and you know the eagles and
stuff
but then but yeah but then they start i
mean that's like 50 years old at this
point right or whatever it is or 40
years old
so it's kind of like so they're playing
that but then they're slowly
incorporating right now we're going to
play 80s stuff yeah not like new wave
but like they're playing the rednecks
yeah yeah yeah and like stuff like that
and then i started noticing that they
started slipping like nirvana in there i
was gonna say that and sound gardening
they played they played your uh and
[ __ ] nickelback and [ __ ] which is
that's from the that's from the early
2000's they were playing nickelodeon
nickelback they were playing [ __ ]
eurythmics they were all that terrible
all that terrible like alt rock from the
late 1990s they were throwing in they
were throwing in [ __ ] um um
[ __ ] what's the [ __ ] what's what
was that band that did [ __ ] the
rooster
oh uh
oh
wait i'll get it i'll get it i'll get it
oh
damn
i can see the dude's face he died right
yeah alex and jane's allison changed i
knew i would think i knew i didn't think
of it a second yeah this would don't
drink like what happened biker music
it's not what it was ten years ago well
like i said you have to think about it
like yeah like [ __ ] from the 90s is old
yeah i mean because [ __ ] man i graduated
from high school in 1990 that was a long
[ __ ] time ago so
you know
it's it
that's the classic rock that was that's
like 20 30 years old you see like these
50 year old [ __ ] biker dudes [ __ ]
just jamming out to alice and chains and
[ __ ]
with their choppers and [ __ ]
well yeah and like i said it's just
funny to me i don't i don't care it's
all it's all funny games
yeah yeah
yeah it's all good because then they'll
come back and buy you buy a drink
well free alcohol is always yeah
it's like all right i'll listen to
leonard skinner for me something they
were handing out the alcohol full big
[ __ ] lay's potato chips bags of lace
potato chips today like the full size
ones not even like the snack sizes yeah
no no not snack size the full size don't
even give me a whole thing of your legs
but i will eat that whole thing and they
were the vinegar ones
oh
yeah even better yeah
so me and this 80 year old [ __ ] biker
were sitting there [ __ ] eating out of
this damn bag of vinegar [ __ ] [ __ ] so
you've eaten the whole entire bag yeah
me and this place like we're like he's
like yeah
i couldn't understand the word he's
saying he's [ __ ] poor
that's right that'd be a [ __ ] she said
what that is you know what i'm talking
about yeah sure whatever man yeah that's
exactly what's going on
hey
bust your ass open
oh yeah yeah
that's an old that's an old
that's chestnut guy he used to know back
in the old days
i forgot what was that dude's name you
told me that's what he used to say
did he bust your ass
[Laughter]
and i'm like wait what does that even
mean that sounds like a threat
can we talk about how
i can't believe like you would so
seriously not only do you have all that
alcohol today yeah you also ate like a
whole bag of lay's vinegar potato chips
and a whole bag of [ __ ] doritos
the truth comes out so and then you have
the audacity the temerity yeah to come
home and say how hungry you are [ __ ] i
haven't eaten a single goddamn thing i
have three cups of coffee today and
that's all yeah
but but it was it was the snack size bag
of doritos the nacho cheese doritos
well snack size is those little bitty
ones yeah like you put in your kids
lunchboxes yes one of those i thought
you just said that the lays one was the
delay was the full size oh okay
being an old man [ __ ] so the snack
size that's there's like three doritos
yeah seriously that's like not even that
big idea they were throwing those around
they just brought in a whole bag and
started tossing them
to people
see that's what they because they're
like yeah get get your mouth all nice
and salty
so you like need some water
one of my favorite things when i was a
kid is you'd get a bag of uh the lays
like the plain ones or uh you know the
salt and vinegar ones were good too
you get or uh sour cream and onion also
good you would get those and then you
would get like a chocolate bar like a
hershey bar like just plain one or
whatever and you would like break off a
little thing and like put it on top of
the lazy potato chip and eat that and it
was like it was really really good like
i said i'm glad and honestly when i was
a kid because when i was a kid we didn't
have all this fancy-schmancy [ __ ] like
[ __ ] chocolate with sea salt on it
like you can get easily nowadays back
then i was like why does anybody sell
this [ __ ] it's like it's so good like
salty chocolate is so good and i don't
understand why nobody sells like
chocolate covered potato chips but well
i mean now they do but back in the 70s
teeth went off the [ __ ] i was way
ahead of my uh i was way ahead of my
time i guess he's laughing there's a
jukebox yeah
mr roboto says jenny you definitely need
to go to the biker bar i will
yeah it should go but like i said i'll
have to take like some i don't know i'll
just take like some [ __ ] something to
entertain myself in case i could yeah
brad jones says i'm ripped as [ __ ] yeah
i'm ripped
you just see my legs my legs are
actually twice as ripped as if
sandra said i would get dizzy if i
didn't eat for such a long time yeah i
do sometimes it depends
um
but at some point it's like i kind of
get used to not eating for long periods
of time because sometimes i forget
and uh you know but i don't know it's
not too bad today i'm pretty hungry but
if i get hungry i just chew gum or i
drink coffee
we got so much food out there we can eat
i got [ __ ]
tacos i got carnitas made we can even go
up to [ __ ] we could go up and get
chinese food we could get japanese we
just had chinese food yesterday though
yeah whatever you want cause that was
okay so that was another thing and i was
a long time ago when we were talking
about going to when we were going to the
movies
yeah
we were going to the movies weirdly i
know we talk about dead malls a lot
right but for whatever reason we go to
like the altamonte springs 18 theater
like the amc oh you should have seen it
man we [ __ ] ate like
well and across the street well it's
kind of in the same complex uh is the
altmont mall for whatever reason the
outsmart mall we went there it was like
thursday in like the middle of the
afternoon and it's always crowded and
honestly even though a couple of the
anchor stores like the dillards like
that's there's people in there and
there's people shopping but it's like it
it needs to be like refurbished because
it smells kind of moldy because i think
their ceiling is [ __ ] up but other
than that there are hardly any empty
stores in there and no matter what time
of day you go
like even in a midweek like
mid-afternoon and stuff there's always
people in there there's always tons of
people the food court is always like
like at least three quarters full
there's housing projects there well it's
well there's like a [ __ ] ton of
apartment complexes there's a [ __ ] ton
of office buildings so a lot of people
go over there for a lot for lunch and
stuff like that um so a lot of people
like live and work like right around
there for 10 bucks you can go there
there's a chinese restaurant and you can
get an entire [ __ ] huge it's a pile i
couldn't i couldn't eat at all i'm like
yeah i'm in a bar of chicken
chicken
[ __ ] chicken this i can just give you
some more that chicken and i'll give you
some he wants my bourbon chicken so yeah
give me some more chicken and they'll
[ __ ] pile that [ __ ] on because
they're trying to get rid of it
they're like look it's just gonna sit
here let's just sit here good they're
huge i just got a little bit of noodles
i got some beef and broccoli and i got a
big thing of sesame chicken
the thing about it though so we went to
the food court because it's been a long
time since we had been there because we
got to the mall like went to the movie
theater it was like way too early and we
were like okay well let's go to the food
court and get something to eat
and
i was gonna go to we they used to have a
nature's table in there and they had
like a pretty sweet like turkey panini
and they also had really good tomato
soup so i was gonna get some of that but
that was closed all the other [ __ ] was
open
but that one had closed in the interim
sadly um
and so i was like well [ __ ] i guess i'll
get chinese food um but then i forgot
there's another restaurant there it's
what's it i don't even remember what
it's called mediterranean i think it's
just called mediterranean grill it has
like some generic name and they have
like a really really good like steak
sandwich and like greek salad and stuff
and i forgot with the feta cheese and
all that yeah and it was like i got the
chinese food and that was good but then
i was like looking i was like ah i
forgot that [ __ ] was here yeah oh the
ice cream and coffee place had clothes
too but other than that everything else
was open there's like a philly
cheesesteak place there's a taco bell in
there there's a chick-fil-a in there
what the [ __ ] else is there's an indian
restaurant yeah um not a red well it's
like a buffet type just like the chinese
place but it's indian food look it's 6
13.
yeah which one do tonight i don't know
okay
you want to eat mr robot i said jenny do
you have a sweet leather jacket i do not
tom has one yeah do you still have it oh
yeah do you still have it yeah it's
biker jacket
straight out of [ __ ] uh terminator
one yeah yeah
i got a whole terminator one outfit
actually with the gargoyle glasses and
everything
but i shaved my head so
it was better when i had hair
well you got wigs yeah i got wigs you
could be the terminator with an amadeus
wig on yeah
or a mullet that's fun if you did that
though it's like i don't think anybody
would realize that it was a costume
they would just think that was how you
dressed right
i don't know why i just thought of this
i guess because i was talking about a
mullet but when we were at the mall
yesterday we went in the fye
they have a whole line
of tiger king branded stuff oh yeah she
was funny they had like they have tiger
king chili yeah licking cans
and it's so funny because like whoever
graphic designed it i was just kind of
like i see what you did there um because
it's just like super like over the top
tacky and i'm like oh my god i love it i
just love that you like tapped right
into that they also have
a tiger king
cereal what the [ __ ] was it called
i can't remember it had like a really
funny name because i pulled it out and
like showed it to tom oh my god what the
[ __ ] was it called because yeah that's
like fye has all of this because they
have all this anime stuff so they have
like all this japanese
uh candy and snacks and stuff like in
the front and so of course we were going
to the movies so he's like oh i have to
get all these gummies which gross i was
like why can't you get like good candy
for once but you know you just got
gummies and they didn't really have
anything
they had like some other like they had
pocky and they had like some kind of
like chocolate candy but none of it was
like small enough to like fit in my
purse
so because my purse is that big so
because i told him i was like you can
buy all the gummies you want but i'm not
carrying that [ __ ] in my purse because
it doesn't fit so you're gonna have to
put it in your goddamn pockets
um but they didn't have any god i wish i
remember the name of it
just [ __ ] it was called savage
pops or no that wasn't it although that
would be funny but it was something like
that
but it was like alliterative like it had
the same letter at the beginning but i
couldn't remember what it was
like tiger type i don't know i don't
remember what it was but yeah ferocious
flakes that's what it was thank you
victor thank you for googling it because
i was i knew i said that both starts
with the same letter but it's like it
made me laugh like when i saw it
ferocious flakes yeah it's got [ __ ]
tiger king on there and it's like and
they had it they had chili
and then they had hot sauce like the
chili like in a can and then like the
hot sauce and then they had one other
thing but i couldn't remember what it
was like they were in two different
places but it was just like i was just
like oh my god really we're still on the
tiger cake thing all right that's i
don't know hilarious yeah ferocious
flakes
tom is the tiger king
[Laughter]
i don't have the hair for it well like i
said that's why you have the mullet wig
right
tammy says uh i'm sipping banana cream
moonshine
oh [ __ ] that sounds good banana it does
it really it really doesn't but i mean
i don't like bananas i like banana
flavor i'm thinking of like [ __ ] um
you know banana moon pies like a banana
moon pie we'll see that's what i was
thinking too and that's why i was kind
of it's just redneck as [ __ ] it is
that's honky as [ __ ]
oh well see the thing about nana moon
pies is that i do not like banana and
nor do i like marshmallow so it's kind
of like that's two things that i don't
like together so
i'll tolerate marshmallow
if it's
um
you know paired with other things that
are actually good
but
if it's with banana then you can [ __ ]
right off with that seriously
dj maniac says [ __ ] tiger king cereal
i'm all about monster cereal this time
of year just ordered two family size
boxes of monster mash from amazon do
they still have
like what even flavor is that i mean i'm
sure they still sell like count chocula
and franken berry and blueberry and all
that what was the other one fruit brew i
don't know go ahead and give us a like
people go ahead and hit that thumbs up
and we got we got about 50 people in
there right now it'd be a good time for
a thumbs up if you guys forgot about
that good time for him it's a good time
for thunder thumbs up it's also a good
time for a super chat but instead of san
diego we've actually gotten a lot of
super chats
which i was not expecting like we were
just like digging around whatever yeah
um you know bananas foster is a great
easy dessert to make to impress your
guests yeah and honestly i i have a
little bit of a story about bananas
foster is that when i used to i used to
work at that print shop over there in
longwood and there was a 7-eleven next
to it so sometimes for breakfast i go
over there and like get a cup of coffee
because 7-eleven actually has decent
their iced coffee is good and they had
hot coffee too but they only had like
two or three flavors
like in the machine like they have a
bunch of flavors
like on the in the pots or whatever
thank you victor
here buy yourself a dq blizzard yeah
ooh i might with the heathen roboto says
jenny you dislike marshmallow or it's
just the taste of the smell what is it
um i don't hate them but it's just kind
of like it's never something that i
choose it always just seems kind of like
i love it
i like it
okay there's just nothing
nothing excites me about it
like i said if it's kind of like like i
like s'mores
and [ __ ] like that but see i like
s'mores because one there's chocolate
and two it has like crunchy graham
cracker [ __ ] going on in it too so it
like offsets the mushy blanus of the
marshmallow
so you know what i mean so
you know and honestly about it honestly
if you gave me a cup of cocoa
and it had marshmallows in it i'd be
like i'm not happy about it but i'd be
like okay it's still hot cocoa you know
what i'm saying so it's not like a deal
breaker yeah um
it's just nothing that i would like
choose i like it all
well there's marshmallow and rocky road
ice cream man yeah and i'll eat that
but see that has other crunchy [ __ ] in
it too that has like crunchy [ __ ] and
honestly you have to have crunchy [ __ ]
to offset
like i said the mushy marshmallow stuff
okay so yeah so i was at 7 11 one of
those mornings
and one of the flavors of coffee that
they had that morning was bananas foster
and i was so offended i was just like oh
no
gross and then i just left without
getting any
yeah i don't know what it is it's just i
don't dislike a lot of things i'll eat
pretty much anything well yeah not
pretty much anything but i'll eat a lot
of things
um
and tila are sitting there bitching
about the dangerous and hot things that
exist in florida about moving to florida
look
if you want to know what florida's like
[ __ ] sandra i know you're up there in
germany alemanya okay you're up there
with the [ __ ] in germania as the
[ __ ]
romans would say
watch a movie
called pain and gain
it has the rock in it
and who else is in it has [ __ ] uh
that wahlberg fell yeah yeah mark
wahlberg and wahlberg
fellaini it's a true story
it's a true crime story it's called pain
and gain
about a dude and that's the way florida
is kinda
yeah
when i saw that movie i was i [ __ ]
loved it i think [ __ ] louis hernandez
sent me that movie
i think
and [ __ ] i think that thanked him for
it i was like oh god damn this movie
this this movie is florida as [ __ ]
it really is but um florida is so weird
sandra i've been to germany
i've known germans before
germans would love florida it's very
different from germany
it has a very good quality
it's good quality [ __ ] great food it is
a little hot especially in the summer a
little yeah it's hot in the summer's hot
but um
there's a lot of fun [ __ ] to do it is
very ungerman very ungerman in some ways
just because it's it's wild you know i
mean everybody is about control and
order and [ __ ] things being not
florida florida's like central america
you know the weird thing is like every
british person i knew um that came to
florida like on vacation they thought it
was the greatest thing ever well they
loved the heat i couldn't
i'm like and i was born here i was born
in florida and um i can't stand it we
had a british muslim girl come visit us
as a friend of ours and she [ __ ]
loved it love the heat took her to a
mexican restaurant with a real mexican
restaurant with dudes from mexico
working on lawn cruise and [ __ ] he just
[ __ ] loved it he was like oh man it's
great
i had a yeah i had a british friend
what's the street from the biker bars
just came from actually yeah i had i had
a
a friend that was uh that was british
and he came here for like an extended he
went all around florida and he just he
it couldn't get hot enough for him he
just thought it was fantastic i'm like
you must be tripping this is a complete
180 degrees from europe it is a 180
degrees from europe
uh but haven't having lived in brazil
and everything it's it's like south
america more than
more than
north america or europe it's like it's
like yeah it's kind of like a weird it's
like understanding florida's like a
weird like schizophrenic place yeah it's
weird because there's just so much like
influence from so many other places it's
like everything
thrown into a pot and like it just comes
out in like these bizarre ass ways yeah
it's south american it's central
american but it's but it's also like
[ __ ] southern at the same time yeah
it's all kind of weird [ __ ] going on
here
um
yeah tila said you have to dust your
body down with baby powder when you
visit florida yeah honestly yeah well
well yeah you do
um you don't have big giant boobs
so you got to put like [ __ ] you got
to put baby powder under the boobs
otherwise you chafe see a man is going
to want to come he's going to [ __ ]
grab [ __ ] and this and then he's like
yes right he's gonna [ __ ] try well
that doesn't have anything to do with
like i'm gonna need to lift the titties
and [ __ ] blow on it like
yeah but you're not doing that 24 7.
yeah it's not too much
so you really like me or you need to put
deodorant under there which you're
really not supposed to do but well
uh if you're in a civilized household it
is
air-conditioned you just can't live
inside you just can't go outside yeah
you can't live i wouldn't advise it you
can't live in florida without air
conditioning
no like i said you'd be miserable you'd
be miserable yeah uh victor said yeah
bath and body works has marshmallow and
pumpkin or some [ __ ] and it smells so
good see it probably does smell good i
kind of feel like marshmallow especially
if it was mixed with something else and
i had some coffee like i had this uh
little mixture that had like 40
different flavors of coffee in it it had
like a chocolate marshmallow one that
was actually pretty good but so like i
said it's mixed with other things
i don't even know what marshmallow
smells like it just kind of smells like
sugar just saying sandra said i'm scared
of florida
sandra if you ever want to come here and
visit us just [ __ ] contact me and
i'll put you through the [ __ ] initial
[ __ ] screening
i gotta scream it [ __ ]
and uh if you pass screening
[ __ ] you can come down you have to
get accepted by tom before you're
accepted into florida yeah we'll scream
he's like the gatekeeper yeah and then
you come back well hey man i screamed a
lot of [ __ ] that came down [ __ ]
sophie from from uh michigan [ __ ]
screened her turned out i knew her
anyway
we'll see there you go turned out
[ __ ] i went to high school with all
her [ __ ]
friends
older brothers and sisters so
it's it's a small world
yeah
just like i said well we found out
earlier blake with dj maniac talking
yeah
dj maniac turns out he knows dude we've
been doing we've [ __ ] been hanging
out with doing business in the scene
haven't seen octavia in a while like he
moved away didn't he i think he moved to
well he did it he doesn't know in
philadelphia he doesn't call culture
shock right time for time for him to
come back and he does uh yeah but i know
he does like one off nights he's done
one in philadelphia because i remember
doing a flyer for that and he does them
in miami because i've done a couple
flyers for those too but it's like when
he's going through town
he knows everybody in like orlando and
tampa and stuff we just we see him out
every now and then but yeah he's a cool
dude i like him
um
screening yeah i guess green yes tila
said would you would you all consider
renting out your room um we don't have
any rooms available because because the
room that what was um was originally
available is now a gym yeah
uh
but no we we can we can take
some
guests if we like you and you pass
screened and we can take some but
um
that's actually more like maybe three or
four months from now we got [ __ ] we got
to do right here
i mean really like the office looks good
i have all the everything set up in here
but pretty much every other room is just
kind of like
it's not i mean the bedroom
we at least got the curtains put out we
got it nice more curtains up in the
other rooms we have so i'm not waking up
at the ass crack of dawn every morning
because the sun's blaring in this main
um this living room
i want to put some [ __ ] stand-up
video games in there i want a pac-man i
want to go like galaga i want that [ __ ]
to look like a [ __ ] arcade and it's
going to have a bar in it too yeah we
definitely need a bar yeah
and maybe a second coffee station
because i actually have a little coffee
station over there i wanted another
refrigerator up here too yeah we
definitely yeah we do on the bar i want
a small refrigerator that [ __ ] lights
up that [ __ ] looks pretty maybe has
something to do with red bull or
something i don't know i can get one of
those from like [ __ ] we got friends
well yeah we could talk to big tom so
yeah we're talking to the guy that they
got that one's made we have some guys
everyone's bar
[Laughter]
it's like hey give us some [ __ ] whatever
you want like red bull refrigerator yeah
you have like a red bull branding on it
yeah that's another thing that's another
thing you love those energy drinks man
yeah i love energy drinks yeah okay
like i said they just like they taste
like gross ass like stale sweet darts
yeah [ __ ] so nasty nasty kids is okay so
the bakersfield area she took well she
didn't trust straw dog oh i think i lost
the
thing again my [ __ ] weren't yeah yeah it
went it uh left over here too just wait
oh went back to green back to green okay
it'll take okay it's good here oh god
damn it
it's like stressing me out it's all
right [ __ ] it's stressful well we've
been we've been uh streaming for how
long hour and a half
yeah it's almost time for two hours
about two hours
i got i gotta cook man and we gotta get
ready for tonight
yeah that's right so we are gonna go
right yeah we're gonna go yeah a little
hiccup yeah it's kind of like i said i
have a little square here that on obs
which yeah if your connection's good
it's like green but then it starts
splashing like red and yellow but if you
lose it
tina said yep tom is demonstrating what
those florida men do when you first
arrived she's saying that to sandra i'm
not sure exactly what you're talking
about
tila
uh to try to put me with the other
florida guys
i'm not a florida man i'm a man but i'm
not from i'm not from florida i live in
florida i'm a mississippi man
um
i think
florida man is a special kind of yeah
a florida man is a lot different
well not really a lot different but i
mean there are similarities depends on
what happened
but like what happened
i mean i kind of feel like you remember
that story that you told about
um
blowing up what was it like blowing up
the anvils oh yeah
that's like some that's like some
florida man [ __ ] that's that's something
well i know that but i'm just saying
that's something a florida man would
like come up with
oh
okay let's see what what what a [ __ ]
what what anvil shoot is all about and
kind of grew up with this
if you take
a [ __ ] flat
piece of metal and and you have your
friend cut a hole in it
and then take a pipe and put that onto
that
and then [ __ ] put screw the end of
the pipe on
then we have a tube with a flat plate
you can pour a whole [ __ ]
one to 10 pounds of [ __ ] rifle powder
or black powder down into this [ __ ]
hole in a metal plate
and you bury it into the ground and you
use
you use levels and see make sure it's
straight up and down and then stick a
[ __ ] anvil on top of it
and put some fuse in there and set it on
fire and the explosion will blow that
anvil way up into the air
and the idea is
is to [ __ ] blow the anvil up into the
air and have it come down and hit the
plate that you launched it from
and not fall on somebody's head
ideally it's got to be straight up and
down
[Laughter]
you do this during the super bowl my
dad's friends were doing this
because that makes total sense it makes
total sense it would go off and like
boom a huge explosion and the [ __ ]
anvil would go about [ __ ] hundreds of
feet in the air
and then [ __ ] stop and then come back
down
so it went off like a cannon
the first time i saw that [ __ ] happen
they were sitting there and they got the
anvil sitting on top of the plate they
got it loaded up they got the [ __ ]
and they're trying to adjust it
so it's straight up and down so it'll
come back down and they launch that
anvil boom
look at the shock wave [ __ ] rattles
all the windows from all the [ __ ]
houses
and i'm watching the apple go up
[Laughter]
okay
and it gets up there and it hangs and it
starts to come down and when it's coming
down the dog that was standing next to
started barking at it and running after
the [ __ ] house
no no no no no no no no no and then the
[ __ ] dog runs across the yard i'm
right behind and the dog jumps up into
the air and tries to [ __ ] catch the
anvil in his teeth oh no
doc didn't get hurt he missed no he
missed
the [ __ ] dog
snap to the damn anvil missed it
and then fell and it fell where the
anvil hit when the angle hit the ground
it made a [ __ ] crater about two feet
deep
and then the [ __ ]
the dog it was a [ __ ] pit bull the
pit bull
fell into the hole that the anvil made
and i was about
16 17.
i was [ __ ] just astounded it was like
something out of a movie
see that's the thing with the dog that's
kind of like why i would never do that
type of thing because it's like they're
dog
so many unforeseen consequences yeah uh
that could come with that i hear but
yellow no no no no no no because yeah
like i said dudes don't think i thought
obviously i hadn't thought obviously hey
listen yeah they don't think of anything
other than hey let's blow up an anvil
that'll be super cool they don't think
about like where it's going to land at
and the dog trying to catch it right um
but see that's exactly the kind of [ __ ]
that i think of doug which is why i
don't do that kind of stuff jumped up
tried to catch it it [ __ ] snapped in
the air just with his teeth
just as the anvil passed it it [ __ ]
hit the ground and
made a huge crater and the dog midair
fell into the hole with the [ __ ]
anvil
and i was just like standing there
and the dog
dog's back feet were sticking up out of
the way i got it
dog's back feet were sticking up out of
the hole his head was down there with a
hammer and
i was like whoa
and then he jumped up like that and
turned around and looked at me like
where'd it go it's like it's right there
but you know they're dogs the dog can't
really grasp what's happening and i
[ __ ] grab the dog took the big old
pit bull
took the took the [ __ ] pit bull
they're popping then they locked the dog
up in the house
like oh yeah duh we should have thought
of that she should have thought of that
[ __ ] before but yeah they never knew
though
they don't think and then they're like
ah
who could have foreseen
everybody everybody could have foreseen
yeah and actually i wasn't 17. i must
have been more like [ __ ] 19 because
it seemed like a couple months later i
was in the army
so it must been around 19
at the time camp guy said i just went to
a pumpkin patch october experience they
shot a pumpkin out of a pressurized air
cannon yeah that's kind of that's
something they do a lot yeah i'm sure
they probably do that around here
yeah there's like a pumpkin patch around
yeah this is like always around october
they're like hey let's shoot some
pumpkins i'm like hey don't waste all
that pumpkin i can make pie out of that
or bread
or curry or lots of things yeah you know
like i said
i love pumpkin
and you can cook so much stuff with it
and honestly now that i'm thinking about
it [ __ ] man it's only like nine days to
halloween maybe we should get some
pumpkins
and make some stuff we get the pumpkins
after halloween
cheaper don't don't be that way
so i don't so i don't even get to make
jack-o-lantern okay well uh how many how
many days we have what nine days okay
we'll get something out people don't let
me have any fun i'll put the uh i'll put
the uh the halloween lights up
yeah well we've been talking about that
for like a week and you still haven't
done it yeah come on all right
guys it's like seriously it's like two
lights all you have to do is like stick
them in the ground and plug it in yeah
you know what's funny when we were
coming back from the movies yesterday
uh we saw a truck that was coming out of
one of the like rich neighborhoods that
we passed by and it was like one of
those christmas decorating services yeah
and i was just kind of like lights up
for you well yeah well some of that i
mean that neighborhood in particular
there's like some really big and they do
like a lot of them do really elaborate
[ __ ] for christmas although it seems
like really early to be doing [ __ ] for
christmas maybe they do [ __ ] for
halloween too and then i said maybe i
should start a business decorating
people's houses for halloween that'd be
fun not christmas though because [ __ ]
oh stop it oh no pookie yeah i knew she
was gonna she's actually been uh been
good
okay it's getting
late just go ahead and victor says my
jack-o'-lantern only has one hole yeah
just go ahead and close this out i'll
make something to eat for us okay you
sure it's only an hour and 45 minutes we
haven't gone that long it's okay all
right we are kind of hungry though yeah
we're getting hungry and uh there isn't
a whole lot of action all right and
we're yeah we're gonna go to mannequins
tonight yeah
i guess so i have to like start
start all over with this face because i
have this makeup on all day fun come on
okay so we got to eat some tacos or
whatever it is that you're making yeah
so yeah thanks for dropping by everybody
thanks for all the super chats got way
more super chats tonight than i was
expecting uh we will be back on sunday
talking about i don't know movie
probably or something and uh so we'll
see you guys then have a good weekend up
until we see you next time
bye